be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so continuing our discussion on all-new
all-different marvel and civil war 2
what I wanted to do here is have a
discussion about the all-new
all-different Ultimates and what I'm
hoping is that by the end of all this
you'll have a strong understanding of
the team as well as how they originated
and the Marvel prime universe that said
as we get into this something I want to
do here is take a step back and clarify
the difference between the new version
of The Ultimates and the team as it
existed in the Ultimate Universe in 2000
when model looked to reinvent their
lineup for newer audiences as part of
the overall idea to reconstruct existing
concepts into something new the Avengers
team was reimagined in 2002 under the
writing and artistry of Mark Millar and
Brian hitch respectively rechristening
the team as The Ultimates originally
consisting of Captain America Bruce
Banner Hank Pym Janet Pam and Tony Stark
the team was originally assembled as a
government-sponsored strike force under
director Nick Fury and later joined by
four during their efforts to subdue
Bruce Banner after transforming into his
Hawk form existing as a series of
limited runs spanning 13 to 15 issues
over six volumes the ultimate served to
represent the real-life war on terror
within the comic book realm facing their
own trials and tribulations against both
public opinion and government oversight
regarding their own actions and the
reception of both Bruce Banner and Thor
to this end with various writers
including Jonathan Hickman and Jeff Lowe
providing their own take on the team and
how their stories unfolded most all
underlying concepts remain the same and
that the ultimate served at the pleasure
of the US government were led by Nick
Fury and operated out of the Triskelion
an island based military installation /
prison not unlike his depiction and the
Marvel films however with the intention
of Marvel to relaunch its company-wide
branding is all-new all-different
following the conclusion of Secret Wars
The Ultimates team as it existed within
the Ultimate Universe was removed and
replaced with the all-new all-different
iteration of black panther Miss America
Carol Danvers Monica Rambeau and Adam
Brashear
written by Al Ewing and drawn by Kenneth
raka for during a 2015 interview with
comic book resources prior to its launch
al Ewing had stated that the Ultimates
title was not designed to be a
continuation of the all-new
all-different marvel line and instead
had used the Ultimates name to indicate
that the team dealt with ultimate
problems threatening both the Marvel
prime universe and the multiverse itself
while the series initially introduced
its various characters without any kind
of backstory with issue number 8 tying
in to the events of Civil War 2 the
origin of the team was finally revealed
taking place at some point following
Carol Danvers appointment to the leader
of sword and miss Alpha Flight Strike
Force Danvers had come to the conclusion
that with sword operating to serve a
foreign world's assess their threats to
earth and catalogue the information the
organization operated in a defensive
capacity and couldn't be everywhere at
once
as a result Danvers looked to create a
branch off team of sword proper which
would operate alongside the organization
but in a more free-flowing capacity
allowing the team to travel within the
universe assessing threats directly and
reporting their findings back to sword
initially enlisting black panther owing
to a combination of his intelligence
influence in the political community and
wakanda's various technologies black
panther agreed to join but also pointed
Carol Danvers in the direction of Adam
Brashear now Adam is a character that I
have discussed in previous videos
however that discussion is largely
isolated to his origin story as it was
written by Kevin Griffo in truth
following his initial introduction blue
Marvel did not play a major role within
a larger Marvel landscape instead
because his character possess a level of
power equal to the century and the Hulk
as well as intelligence that placed him
near to Reed Richards the various
writers of Marvel Comics had a hard time
creating relatable stories that centred
on Adam instead blue Marvel was rolled
over into a series of teams including
Luke cages Mighty Avengers and even
battled an alternate reality version of
Hyperion as a result Adam was considered
to be lost on a kind of no man's land
regarding his place in the larger Marvel
landscape to this end the inclusion of
blue Marvel both within and without
Marvel comics provides us with a place
for him to grow and serve some major use
without creating a quagmire of turning
him into a brawl
with no real purpose considering danvers
offer of having the team work in a
capacity more akin to explores instead
of Search and Destroy Anna Brashear
agreed to join and point Carol Danvers
in the direction of a woman named Monica
Rambeau who operates under the moniker
of spectrum now Monica is a character
that we've never talked about before and
this was due to the fact that we didn't
really have a reason to
however with her inclusion into the
ultimates line now seems a good time to
talk about her and offer an explanation
even if it's only on a modest scale
originally created in 1982 by Roger
stern and John Romita Jr Monica Rambeau
was established to be a native of
Louisiana and possess the power to
transform her body into pure energy
while most older fans recognize her as a
third iteration of Captain Marvel behind
the original Marvel of the Creed and
Carol Danvers herself the name of
Captain Marvel was actually bestowed on
Rambo by the media as opposed to taking
it up for herself
Monica's time on the Avengers team spans
some 120 issues including the 90s
maximum security crossover and even saw
her elevated to the team's leader in an
effort to bolster her position among
readers however because Glenn hurdle is
writing style regarding Monica Rambeau
during Avengers unplugged had failed to
resonate with fans during his time on
the series following his departure and
much like Adam Brashear Monica fell to
the wayside becoming an on-again
off-again member of the team
occasionally providing some measure of
assistance to the group as a result in
between the late 1990s going into the
mid 2010 s Monica went through a series
of character changes and was
transitioned from one team to the next
including the Thunderbolts and the
Mighty Avengers but found less and less
success with each change and so going
into the post Secret Wars landscape
while I haven't been able to find a
reason for it logic would dictate that
the Ultimates line was selected as
Marvel's home for misfit toys allowing
the team to include Monica among its
less successful heroes looking for a
place of normalcy now following this we
pick up with the UN Security Council
something I want to point out here
though is that the UN Security Council
function as the arm of the president
when dealing with national security and
the various threats across the world
that deal with the United States at this
time because the u.s. Security Council
consists of the heads of the various
security agencies around the country
including the FBI and the CIA a man
named Philip Nelson wad is brought on
board as part of the NSA for the purpose
of monitoring the ultimates as a whole
especially blue Marvel in to sidetrack
for a second because the origin of Adam
Brashear involved the issue of racial
problems in the United States during the
1960's with a Kevin Grebo miniseries saw
Brashear stepping down and living out a
quiet life he still remained in the eye
of the US government which continually
monitored him due to both the power he
possessed and what he represented as a
symbol of the black community and to
this end because the only all different
model line continued most of the themes
from the original Marvel Universe The
Ultimates continued to operate as a
branch of the Avengers but sanctioned by
the US government and monitored by the
NSA who operated behind the scenes but
from here we're actually going to bypass
the first four issues of Ultimates and
jump to number five the reason for this
is that the first four issues of the
series actually cover the group's
transformation of Galactus from the
world devourer into life bringer
now if this is something that you're
actually interested in looking at you
can find it in my video on all-new
all-different Galactus explained which
you'll find in the description but
follow me The Ultimates actions towards
Galactus the group shifted their focus
to time itself now the reason why this
matters is that what Al doing does
throughout his time on the title is give
us an idea of how the all-new
all-different marvel universe relates to
the pre secret wars universe but also
it's high in a lot of the concepts that
answer the question about time itself
where common knowledge holds that Marvel
uses branch universe theory and that
every possible action spawns a reality
where the opposite of that action
occurred al Ewing offers a red calm to
this information using a concept called
the doom lock originally introduced an
x-factor volume three issue number 46
and 2009 while the concept was only
mentioned the doom lock was created by
Victor Von Doom and allowed individuals
to move back and forth through time
without creating divergent timelines as
a result instead of cable traveling into
the past and committing an edge which
would change its future and create a new
timeline a doom lock allows the actions
of cable to affect only the existing
timeline without affecting anything else
however by tying into the events of age
of Ultron because the crossover revealed
time to be a living construct
two axes and wanes and is on the verge
of being broken The Ultimates look to
fix this problem by traveling outside
the known multiverse observe time and
fix it you're traveling outside of all
space and time into regions unknown
during their journey the ultimate
stumble across a man named Connor Sims
also known as the ante man not a side
track again Connor Sims was a character
that we had talked about during my
discussion on blue marvel's origin and
that the anti man had suddenly appeared
on earth and laid waste to the Avengers
leading to their mad dash to locate
Brashear during which time the entirety
of Connors origin story was provided as
it was stated when Brashear had worked
to develop the particle accelerator for
both Adam Hershiser and Connor Sims were
blasted with particle energy allowing
them to manipulate antimatter atoms will
Aquila structure remain intact however
for Connor Sims much like a Jenga game
the blocks of his molecules were
unstable and missing in certain places
requiring him to fill the holes using
antimatter as an energy source while
this did allow Connor an extraordinary
amount of strength and speed at the
conclusion of blue marvel's origin story
Adam had created another particle
accelerator and used it to disperse the
atoms of Connor Sims across all space
and time effectively killing him now how
it is that Connor had reformed was never
explored after Kevin Grover's original
story and the Connor Sims was never
brought back but with his return during
aliens run a Ewing actually doesn't
provide an answer to this instead
Connor is given to us as part of an
ongoing story and that after rescuing
him and bringing Connor aboard the ship
Connors power to sense a manipulate
antimatter allows the Ultimates to
access a gateway to the space beyond the
multiverse from here we begin to
intertwine with my all-new Galactus
video and that after travelling into the
depths of pure emptiness the group is
stocked by calacas himself who was said
by eternity and his efforts to keep the
Ultimates from discovering an unknown
secret to creation now exactly what the
secret is seems to be held by a Ewing as
a reveal from waffle now 2.0 but with
Connor Sims on board he informs a group
that some kind of force has placed a
barrier around all reality keeping them
from escaping and chaining the cosmic
entity eternity following this where the
Ultimates are returned to the Marvel
prime reality
galactus my videos on the Cosmic Cube
all new Thanos all new Galactus and all
new Celestials come together for a
larger picture revealing the Thanos had
entered the Marvel prime universe
through a portal opened by Galactus
after returning The Ultimates to earth
and had looked to take possession of the
Cosmic Cube as it was created by project
Pegasus during avengers standoff leading
to a battle against the Avengers
themselves alongside the Ultimates who
had been forewarned of Thanos his
arrival by ulysses of the Inhumans for
the Avengers and The Ultimates defeated
Thanos but lost James Rhodes in the
process after Thanos was captured by
shield and held at the NSA The Ultimates
the Avengers at the x-men the Inhumans
and various other groups came together
in their efforts to defeat a celestial
from another reality kick-starting the
events of Civil War 2 and the question
of whether ulysses ability to see the
future was a gift or a curse for
humankind with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end and
let me know how you guys feel about the
Ultimates I'm a little curious and I
will catch you all later peace